hi I'm David and I'm gonna show you how
to build your own spider-man web
shooters you can build your own
spider-man web shooters using some
simple everyday objects from around the
house or from a hardware store we spent
less than twenty dollars to build this
web server
you will need a wristwatch superglue an
old belt a black plastic spoon a red
plastic circle a coax rg6 crimp-on
connector velcro squares scissors to
make the red plastic circle take a piece
of red packaging plastic measure and cut
the right size circle according to the
size of the watch and then cut it into a
circle remove the back of the watch and
its components place in the red circle
put back the components and reattach the
back glue on the coax connector which
works as a webbing spray nozzle cut the
belt into a properly shaped leather cuff
measured appropriately around your
wrists attach velcro to the leather cuff
cut and trim the spoon into the length
you need for your wrist it will be your
pressure plate to activate the webbing
attach your plastic pressure spoon to
the fastened cuff secure and attach the
watch with the velcro onto the leather
cuff firmly now if you really want your
device to be authentic you can hook up
an Oscorp microprocessor and program it
just like Peter Parker did then order
some Oscorp bio cable made from spiders
inject the webbing capsules accordingly
and you've got a real live working
spider-man web shooter now that you've
built your web shooter it's time to test
it out
works pretty good so that's the
spider-man web shooter thanks for
watching be sure to click to subscribe
to super comics funtime for more
superhero content
you